this is a production of Cornell
University
so well of welcome and let's see what we
can say here this is the title this talk
is based on a paper that's been
published in geo derma of last year and
I want to first give credit to my
co-authors i should say before so you
won't be disappointed i don't actually
have any citizen science data that I've
worked on myself so the idea of this
paper was the second author is Miss
masilleo who's a PhD student at
Wisconsin under professor at jewel who's
an old colleague of mine though I work
with a lot in China he's at Wisconsin
and China and sure whole thesis her own
PhD thesis is on using volunteered
geographic data which is a big issue and
she came to visit me here a couple of
years ago a year and a half ago and we
got talking about could this be used for
the area that I'm most interested in
which is digital soil mapping and we
decided well let's sit down and and
write a concept paper about this which
is what we've done and the third author
are many of you know Steve Carlisle is a
retired soil surveyor lives up in Aurora
and a very keen observer not only of the
soil landscape but a quite a thinker
about interacting with the different
stakeholders so he gave us a lot of
really good ideas and so we have him
together so it's based on this paper and
if you like to read the paper then
you'll learn more to my great amazement
after a little bit of a few weeks it was
then actually cited in an nature
editorial as an example of even soil
scientists are thinking about citizen
science so it was like citizen science
is a big deal which I'll explain in a
minute but wow even Saul science is
getting involved and they kind of took
my abstract and put it here so that was
pretty cool but the paper has not been
cited too many times so I don't know if
anyone has done much with it but anyway
I mention in nature makes my mother
proud very good anyway some of you may
well know about citizen science I want
to get the background in citizen science
then talk about how it's being used in
soil science more in general but then
focus in on could it be used
in the more technical aspect of soil
mapping and that's my my main interest
but let's talk about citizen science in
a more general sense this quote I can't
remember where that's from actually the
idea here is the citizen and we could
maybe call the non-specialist might be
the word they act as either the observer
the experimentalists but this is within
a structure that's set up by the
professional science that's why we don't
call it a hobby and you'll see in a
minute the difference between
bird-watching is a hobby and
bird-watching a citizen science for
example there's a structure that's been
set up by the scientists within which
the citizen works there are really two
main features for this one of course is
weird greedy as scientists if we can get
people to make observations or do things
for us then that amplifies our effort we
don't have to hire another graduate
student right you know that's good but a
really important effort I think almost
equal is to build citizens support for
science and scientific understanding
making a literate scientifically
literate public is another main
objective and these are sometimes a
little bit in conflict on the one hand
we want this rigorous scientific data
but on the other hand we don't want to
make it too difficult for the citizen to
get involved to get some feeling for
science there's a lot going on your
scientific american has a whole page
with lots and lots of citizen science
projects you can read about as an
example these are just some of the
citizen science projects that are
involved so the connecticut turtle atlas
people are interested where are the
turtles and they try to get people
involved in this herp and herpetology
and so forth but there are lots and lots
of projects in europe we have a whole
citizen science association network and
these are logos of various both
universities such as here we have burned
with university but also an aristotle
university but also all kinds of ngos so
there's a whole movement in china
there's a whole page on this and there's
a lot of
objects that are listed so this is
getting more and more popular let's talk
about probably maybe the most successful
project and one that's very dear to our
hearts here at Cornell because it's a
corsa Cornell example ebird is run by
the Cornell Lab of Ornithology and their
aim is to look at the spatio-temporal
distribution of bird species and what's
the advantage from the point of view of
the lab of ornithology obviously a much
denser network of observations then
could be possible at the professionals
their aim their scientific a min general
of course is understanding bird ecology
this is in the broad sense that's what
they like to do and the ideas in this
case they're having the citizens amplify
their efforts this is their web page and
I didn't update this unfortunately for
now but as even a year ago there were
already almost 10 million observations
that were made and you can view and
explore their data you can contribute
data and so forth there are all kinds of
incentives you see or you can make your
totals and the reason for this is so
successful well let's just look at this
here the areas where they received
observations so they would really like
someone to go up to Siberia which is
very very important area for birds
obviously but I was really surprised by
the density in Mongolia for example so
there must be some active bird watchers
there that's good but you can see a bit
of the problem here spatially in that
the distribution of the observations is
is not done by any kind of sampling plan
it's all volunteered so it's not as if
we an example of superiors may be a good
one you'd say well look this is really
important for migratory bird ecology so
we're going to do a scientific
expedition we're going to go to Siberia
we're going to set up a sampling plan
according to our protocols etc you would
have a very different sampling you can't
really tell this in the United States
but I had a student a couple of years
ago in my my graduate course here
working on e bird data from Chicago and
when you looked at the city of Chicago
the idea was what is a good urban bird
habitat she was trying to look at
habitat that would be suitable from
these observations well you found a huge
observation along Lake Michigan there
were huge numbers of observations
everyone sits there with their scopes
looking at the ducks and the birds when
you got to the south side of Chicago
with a little bit more rougher
neighborhood there were no birds now
this either means there are no birds
there because it's bad habitat or
because no bird watchers like to go
there or because the citizens who live
there aren't so interested in bird
watching but it's obviously I mean this
is a nice example of the danger and I
won't call a danger but a limitation of
citizen science is it's very difficult
if the scientist has to deal with data
that is not a collected according to
some sampling plan you might otherwise
use now why is this so so important you
know why is this getting more important
and one thing of course is the
technology the gps mobile phone has
absolutely revolutionized so many things
you know the social interactions of
teenagers and things like that but also
for us the fact you can go take a
picture it's geo-referenced data capture
apps and you can upload it very easily
has really made it possible for for
anybody really with a very very modest
investment to get involved in this and
almost everywhere you have these these
smartphones all over the world the other
part is this mentality and the idea here
is that we're getting more the idea of
the specialist being different from from
us as an ordinary citizen is going away
quite a bit and examples for example of
reviews yeah you remember you used to
have to buy you know the new york review
of books if you wanted to read a book
review and a new book came out and what
do people think about it you read that
or you read the new york times book book
review now you go on Amazon and everyone
can review the book and that's an
empowering thing and so many people are
used to now doing that and giving their
opinions wicked
tia is a very also very good example let
alone let alone blogs everyone can give
their opinion so people are mentally
more ready to do this so the
professional side is how do they use
this data one is the massive databases
the idea you can make a much better
model you have more observations you
have more points you can make a better
model and the example for the ebird
would be habitat suitability something
like that the other thing that can be
done is now monitoring because people
are out there constantly and for the
example they can report an event like
the first skunk cabbage they see or the
button or a certain first bird or they
can report a toxic a toxic dumps a dump
site for example they found someone that
dumped refrigerators along the side of
the road they can just go report that
and if you're building an environmental
database or a hazardous database you can
you can just do that so you have this
early warning and a time series and
these are both very useful to be
professional scientist now that was a
little bit about in general and there
are lots and lots of examples of citizen
science some more or less successful but
I'd like to now get to soil science what
is different about soil science well the
first thing of course it's a resource
that's very underappreciated or
unappreciated in the in a common in the
popular culture I was interested we had
one of the candidates for our geo
spatial position come in and have these
very nice diagrams at the internet
section spheres and the hydrosphere and
the lit ND and the atmosphere and the
soils were absolutely nowhere there that
was okay soils were implicitly there
how's that and that was interesting to
me because the position was a course on
the soil science department
anyway that was okay but but that just
illustrates and in the popular knowledge
then people don't have much concept of
soils actually maybe we have enough time
I'll tell you nice little story about my
my PhD a exam and that was many years
ago but I had a minor in computer
science so they start to examine me and
Tom Scott who many of you know said okay
well I'm going to ask you some questions
about soils and see what you know so
please write down the orders of soil
taxonomy and then we'll talk about them
so I'm about to write on the board and
the computer science professor
interrupts he says wait wait wait you
just use the word taxonomy is that like
a classification I said yes you said you
mean you can classify soils yes you mean
soils are different I mean are there
differences luckily I knew where the
professor lived in coid Glenn and I
could specifically tell them about their
zola Custer and soils where his house
was and the terrace soils right across
the road in the koi Glenn quarry so I
could illustrate to him there were some
differences and we had a nice a exam but
I always thought was a nice example of a
very intelligent very well-informed
person about many things not
appreciating cells okay second point is
even people that know about soils I
don't think we have any soil hobbyists
I've never heard of anyone who goes out
and looks at soils for a hobby you could
you could go around you say i want to
have seen every order in soil taxonomy I
mean that could be a hobby but I've
never heard of it so
okay okay that's a good point that's a
good point you're like but let's even if
that is true how many birders you have
and you probably maybe some of you were
birders yourself there fanatic they love
their hobby they get out in all weather
in fact right now there are these two
burgers that have set up by this the
Stewart Avenue Bridge I've seen in the
last several days walking down there set
up I think they're looking for eagle or
something i'm not sure what they're
looking for a falcon making a red tail
hawk I don't know but they're set up
there with their scopes and they have
all their gear so they spend all day
there anyway so we don't have I guess
the point is in soils we don't have a
ready-made group of people that already
go out in the field and like to look at
soils a large group but i will talk to
Leigh about that another thing of course
very is the surface soil is the only one
that's visible to the non-specialist and
even if you would dig anyone who hasn't
been trained to look to understand soil
horizon soil structure and so forth
would not really know what they're
looking at are they they'd have a very
crude idea what they would be looking at
therefore and I also mentioned this if
you want to make a consistent
observation even even of texturing you
need some kind of training maybe a few
things like I can estimate how many
stones are on the surface but even then
you know if you've ever done that you
get very fooled if you don't use these
grids to try to say really what is the
percentage of stone so it takes some
training so it's also difficult to have
sort of repeat of similar observations
it's not like the burgers where you go
back to the same location so there are a
lot of difficulties there are some
citizens soil projects and these are the
ones that I know about the first one and
I'll I think I've slides on each one yet
so the first one is from the British
Geological Survey and this is the only
attempt that I know of to try to collect
points oil data that might possibly be
useful for mapping
it's a mobile phone application displays
on the background the general soil type
and it allows people to upload their
observations but I'll explain the
problems with it in a minute opal is a
very impressive effort this is funded by
the UK lottery they have a lottery in
the UK and they take that money and they
can give it to different organizations
based with that make proposals and so
they have this Imperial College of
London has set this up in collaboration
museums and they have all these these
these surveys and soil is one of them
they have six surveys and you'll see
they decided to make an earthworm survey
and you'll see how they did that in
collaboration with a lot of schools then
in the United States we have globe which
several people in our section have
worked on before this was set up by NASA
but the main the interesting thing here
the main purpose was to educate
schoolchildren it wasn't really set up
by scientists to say I want to collect a
lot of data that I can now use in my
scientific project so it's very
important to educate schoolchildren in
in in methods of observe ation of
atmosphere and soil but the main aim was
not to collect the data so here's my
soil and it's it kind of promises a lot
more than it delivers the background in
Europe is the general soil map of Europe
from the jrc but the joint recharge
Center in Italy but the one in England
is only a very very very general parent
material map now why is this the British
Geological Survey which controls the
soil survey data was the old soul survey
of England and Wales was privatised
under the Margaret Thatcher and sold we
give you zero budget you have to make
all your money so they immediately even
though the data was completely collected
with rate payer money they completely
tempted to themselves they only sell it
you can't even buy it they only licensed
it and they don't want to give anything
away for free that's now been taken over
there by the British Geological Survey
but now you see this extremely general
map saying we're on chalk or on triassic
rocks and that's all you can get as a
whole but you can't see the soil map
even though there is a soil map so you
can't go there and say here's where I am
this is what the soil map says when you
upload your information all you can say
is well is it coarse medium are fine and
did you know was it black or white it's
so it's not very useful they are getting
some people uploading things from their
garden but it's I find it really a lost
lost opportunity but you can maybe
decide for yourself this is opal and
they have all these surveys I mentioned
and they have a soil survey what they've
done here they've got a very nicely
worked out protocol for all their
surveys and the reason it's becoming
successful is because they're working
through the schools and have this
they've worked with the teachers and the
schools and they it's mainly school
children as you can see from the kind of
publicity picture but look what they're
holding see you have a nice worm here
are they very happy that they found a
worm and they learn how to describe tell
the different types of worms count worm
density and so forth so that's so the
main thing about there there's soil
survey and you can see all the things
they've done here enter your results
results map earthworm guide and so forth
they've decided to concentrate on the
earthworms and they've made really
really a lot of data in it very much
more consistent and globe here is the
globe they collected data on soil
temperature moisture and so forth at
these various stations and then mainly
through schools and so you see this
teacher's guide and so forth so these
are things they tried to get the
students to to understand but it was
more a teaching effort and I don't think
they've really collected much data that
can be can be used ok now let's get to
narrow down even further into digital
soil mapping which is which is my
interest and some I'm sure you know
about this others maybe not well soil
mapping of course is we would like to
show Spacely the distribution of the
different types of soils either the
properties directly so we'd like to map
the pH everywhere or the soil texture or
soil types according to some
classification system for example soil
series or soil orders
the digital soil mapping just means we
use computer algorithms to speed up or
help this process and we have this
mapping paradigm that goes back that was
that McBratney and his colleagues back
in now it's already 13 years ago so
systematized and everyone uses this
concept and how we work it out is quite
different but he didn't like the corp he
thought corpse didn't sound good if you
know your Jenny equation so he decided
score pan he wanted to make scorpion but
he couldn't think of any I to put in
there so we have score pan and so he put
the a in there instead of time he used
annum time so could have a but there is
something new in here if you know your
Jenny equation the point here is soil
that we see is meant to be not randomly
distributed it's there for a reason so
it's based on the climate it's found in
the organisms that were worked both in
and above the soil the relief so where
it is in the topography the parent
material it developed from the time it
had to develop those are all in the
Jenny equation but here we have two
other factors we have s as a function of
s what is that supposed to mean that's
supposed to mean it's based on the
actual observations we've made that's
why he put it in there so you can't do
this abstract Li you calibrate it based
on actual observations and then the end
here is therefore geostatistics it's
meant to say neighborhood it means that
if you know if you know the soils you've
observed close by it tells you you gives
you some idea of what soils you might
find after you've taken these others in
account so it's just a conceptual way
but what do we do when we now go to
actually use it we like to find a
covariant that covers the whole area we
want to map that each covariant
represents part of that equation and of
course it can be a very complicated I
have a colleague down in Florida
University of Florida Sabina gunvault
and she throws 350 different covariance
in a great big data mining model to try
to figure things out I I'm not really an
advocate of that approach but that's
that's an idea but each of those
covariates are meant to represent
something that would
effect soil development so for example
if you have vegetation indices and you
look at the intensity of the vegetation
or the seasonality of the vegetation
that might tell you something about the
the organic matter that kind of thing so
anyway we we have we need the point
observing is was then the point
observations for the soil and we need
point observations I guess that's the
point we have lots of covariance we have
digital elevation models and derivatives
we have a huge number of remote sensing
products stream networks all kinds of
things like this geology maps but we
don't have or what are very expensive
are making point observations of the
soils so the concept of how we might be
liking to use citizen soil science here
would be to try to find some
observations we could use either in our
model building or even if we built
models with more reliable information
maybe for the model evaluation which
probably shouldn't be called validation
i I've been convinced never to use this
word that's why I put it in quotes
because I was convinced by a colleague
who I worked with in the Netherlands
that a model is never ballad you never
say it's valid you can evaluate it and
see how well it's performing and so
forth but to say it's valid is sort of
like you know you have a validated
driver's license or something so she
convinced me not to do that so I've ever
since been tried to be strict about that
so we can maybe get a philosophical
discussion about is a model ever valid I
don't think so anyway so this is the
question this is what we got our
motivation was to thinking about this I
just show an example digital soil map
just if you have never seen one before
this is arusha in tanzania and one is it
a one kilometer resolution and one is it
a 250 meter resolution of the same area
this is the prediction of in this case
the soil organic carbon concentration in
the top of five centimeters sorry I
didn't show the scale bar I should have
shown that
and you can see so how are you doing
this you haven't been everywhere well
you built some model and you can see
what's happening here is as we go up the
volcano first off we get more volcanic
parent material second we get higher
elevation where it's cooler the organic
matter won't decompose as much and so
forth and there are other factors that
might might come in here but that's how
these maps are made but to certainly to
mill the model and possibly to evaluate
it we need some observations we've liked
someone to go in a lot of these places
and and take a soil sample so why
involve citizens well for us we'd like
to increase the density we think of
course just like the bird just like the
bird watchers or the bird ecologists
we'd get better predictive models if we
had more observations I'm going to get
to this in just a minute and show an
example we would like maybe to correct
mistakes on publish maps because if
you've seen a soil map what you realize
is they're typically made now as
polygons and the surveyor has really not
been everywhere they've been everywhere
they've taken some samples they have a
mental model but they could have made a
mistake and if you have an observation
where it's predicted to be one thing and
you see something else it allows a
professional mapper to say hmm I didn't
go there I didn't take that observation
but if that's a true observation I
better rethink I better rethink my
mental model and will allow them to then
improve the map another way would be to
take a published map and down scale it
or disaggregated so you might have
especially a more general soil map where
it's been done maybe a scale of a
hundred thousand or two hundred thousand
you know there are several soil types in
there but you don't know where but if
other people have gone there that helps
you to make a more detail back so that's
what we'd like to see now society well
number one we'd like to we like the
citizens to have a good idea
appreciation for the soil geography we'd
like them to know there are different
soils that they have different
capabilities that they occur at
different places on the landscape and
the more people we could get out there
looking at soils and realizing this then
we would just be building support for
soil survey in a more general sense
so you know we like we like people to do
this and there's this concept of the
connectivity the soil the people
appreciating soils and thinking as a
citizen about the quality of their soils
the health of their soils in the same
way probably most citizens now are quite
aware of water quality for example they
now clear if their lake is getting
polluted or their if they have
foul-smelling water and so forth so
people have feel connected to their
water resource but often not to soil
resource okay now I what we did after
that my co-authors and I we we're really
thinking who could be the citizen
scientists how could we categorize these
people of course some person might be in
different roles so I'll go through all
these different different types of
people that we might attract to be our
our citizen scientists all of these
groups the interesting thing about this
is these all have a specific culture so
if we want to approach one of these
groups like if I go back here if we want
to i'll i'll talk to the greens or the
gardener's if they all have a culture
right so if you'd like to attract them
you'd have to meet them with the culture
the way of their thinking and making a
project that's attractive to them and
what they do so these are probably very
different types of people and they would
call for a different type of
organization i mentioned the national
culture here because we are interested
of course in doing this around the world
and there's a lot of difference between
national cultures both in terms of the
citizens mentality but also the way that
people would take to sharing data in
other words letting you on their land to
look at data or even if it's my own land
am i willing to share data what are my
cultural norms and so forth and we have
these these other things that are quite
different scientists and the public have
a different relation in different
countries so if you were thinking about
okay so let's talk about the groups one
at a time the first one is yeah do I
call them citizens now I'm talking about
this is the closest to us many people in
the room here would fit certainly in
this you're a research soil scientist
but you're not a so
mapper you're an agronomist you're not a
soil mapper you're a professional and
your educate in your field of course so
we call you an educated citizen so
you're to some degree familiar with
existing soil survey protocols and
products you you're aware there's a soil
survey of a jet if you don't know
exactly you have a general idea that
these exist in what can be done with
them you have an interest in these maps
so you have an idea that if you're
interested in the grotto me your soil
science you you really haven't
interested in a reliable soil map you
have a professional attitude towards
soil information so the concept that you
might get involved in in during your
routine your other work that you're
doing in making certain observations
that would help the soil mappers is not
doesn't seem like such a big stretch so
that would be one type of group this
would involve not so much more just
figuring out a protocol that would not
be too hard for people to do in the
course of their other work so you know
plant breeder goes out they have plant
breeding plots they're out there anyway
what can you what could you ask them to
do as as they're out there that might
help you with your soil mapping that
kind of thing okay now the next of
course are farmers or we might say land
managers it might not be the farmer
themselves it might be the forest or
managing a forestry block or dec forest
or for example these people are familiar
with their portion of the landscape and
mostly they're definitely aware of the
value of soil information the motivation
we're trying to think of the motivation
here and the motivation for the first
group might have been well you know
science is important and you know your
colleague is working to make a better
soil map and if you can contribute to
that you feel well you're increasing the
scientific project in some sense here i
think the they're more interested in in
a more detailed soil map of their area
it's maybe maybe the other areas to
compare land management methods so maybe
they'd like to have a more detailed map
of let's say the county or a surrounding
area but i think the main interest is
saying well if we can
Vincent to supply data they would get
back a more reliable map somehow I think
that would be the motivation to get
farmers involved a big I should say a
bit of a problem with this of course is
is the privacy issue in that in the
United States of course anyone can look
at the soil map and see in general how
your farm is mapped if I'm thinking of
buying your farmer I'm comparing but if
it's a more detailed map maybe maybe I
don't really want that information to
get out that's a bit of a problem now
civil engineers and others involving
instruction or interesting group because
they're the ones who go and see the
subsoil they have road cuts sort of
smiting excavations and so forth so
they're the ones that are already making
their own geotechnical measurements so
they're they're used to this so we
usually only go to two meters and you
know the reason that soil survey only
goes to 2 meters this is a I don't know
if it's a true story but I heard back in
1899 when the Bureau of agricultural
industry was set up Milton Whitney was
arguing with a head of the geological
survey and the geological survey said
you don't we don't need a soil survey we
already we already survey and he said no
no soils are different soils are the
it's this you know everything is
happening in the upper part of the soil
and you're only looking at the geology
and you just call it quaternary geology
and we're looking at the we're looking
at the soil and they had a kind of
argument and they decided that since
bodies were buried to six feet that
would be the limit so okay you can call
that the soil down to six feet which we
now call two meters so I don't know if
that's a true story but in fact there's
been a movement in recent years headed
by the Australians for obvious reasons
because they're in a very old weathered
landscape with like a whole regolith
pathology and they've just been a
special issue and I think Gio derma
about this but a lot of papers on this
where they're saying a look padala g is
the entire regolith down to hard rock
this is all a continuous process and
there's much more conductivity much
deeper in the soil than soil scientists
have thought in the past so
we would actually and USDA is behind
this NRCS they'd like to look deeper of
course that's very expensive you can't
do it routinely but these people looked
at quite some depth so they could be a
good source and here's a picture of
actually this is a soil survey but I
like this picture because it shows an
excavation that was done and we jumped
in we we saw well before they before
they build the buildings here we'll jump
in there and we'll take this opportunity
to see the the soil and the nice thing
is here not only can we see the the soil
where we're taking the observation here
but you can see in the back we get a
very good idea of the very of the
variability which is very hard to do if
you don't have a trench or a pit like
this now I can ask you in this picture
which one is the professor ahead of the
group the one in the chair absolutely
well he's taking no no he's very active
but he's taking the notes so that's okay
this is what my work group at the
Chinese Academy Saul Science Institute
the Chinese Academy of scientists
Sciences take a lot of but this so it's
not a civil engineers but you see the
point that these these people doing the
excavation they have an opportunity
possibly for example just to take photos
for us that would be maybe just enough
if we already have a good idea what the
soil type is here and but we don't have
a real good idea of the variability
let's say of the horizons if someone
just takes a photo back here and sends
it to us that's that's really nice so
this is the kind of thing we might ask
them to do now gardeners a lot of people
think well the gardener's would be a
good choice but i don't i don't think so
week for a couple of reasons first off
the gardeners are just managing one very
site very intensively and second they're
modifying the soil quite a bit so
gardener is an interesting group to work
with for many things but they don't
really help us with digital soil mapping
over over larger areas so I I think
they're enthusiastic people and they're
already made group but I don't think
they're so useful for digital soil
mapping now people will go outdoors
anyway hikers geocachers
these people will go out and they like
to go out anyway I'm thinking they may
be interested in learning more about
their environment and you might be able
to convince them to do something as
they're going along in their regular
outdoor activity we'll talk about what
we might ask them to do well we have the
greens in the organizers the greens
these are people that love the
environment even if they don't always
get out in the environment they love it
somehow and the motive and the
motivation well I'm you know today's st.
Patrick's Day I see we have one person
wearing green so this is good the time I
went down into boston on st. patrick's
day when my orange coat was a bad idea
that was a long time ago anyway well
Northern Irish are Irish too right I
think I don't know anyway but the idea
with the green is it would be if people
are already involved I didn't we didn't
get to to clearly about what they might
do the organizers are an interesting
group really interesting group and some
of you may be in this group if you think
about it these are people that have a
psychological need to live in an
organized world no seriously let me ask
you if you go look at a Wikipedia entry
about something you know about and
there's an incorrect statement there
what do you do do you edit it or you
just go on and say someone else will
edit it a lot of people and I may
include myself partly in this
description say I can't stand that
there's a wrong statement there now why
am I taking my time no one's paying me
to do it to correct and it's not a not a
statement about me or someone I know
it's just a Wong statement I take my
time to organize it openstreetmap is
another really good example of this why
don't we just let the professional
mappers why are people updating
openstreetmap well and I'm thinking in
terms of the soil map if these same
people can be motivated to go look at
the soil map and compare the soil map
that exists with what's really there
they might have a compulsive interest in
sending information in and I don't I
would not downplay this because we've
seen we see really good examples of this
the number of people that every in the
Netherlands you know it's just
unbelievable every bike path
with its width and and its surfaces in
the OpenStreetMap and someone is doing
all this too much time on their hands
too much you know they only work 36
hours a week so you've got some time
it's not like us but they work hard in
the 36 hours okay now let's turn the
over to the other side and say what
information could be provided to us and
how hard would this to be to get and
i'll talk about all of these one at a
time that and you can see the list here
and let's talk about them now the tacit
knowledge is what I might call the local
knowledge of the soil landscape it's not
expressed in really scientific language
you don't really make this is this is
without making a new observation but you
make a comment on a published map or a
comment may be an even an unpublished
map where you say well I know over in
this area it's really really bouldery
really blocky you can never use
machinery over here in the bulbous you
know or hear it's been extremely high I
look at my photos over there oh it's
really really eroded over there the
gullies are everywhere you've the
subsoil is coming through and this kind
of knowledge where without making a new
observation the person who knows their
land very well can either comment on a
publish map or they can make a sketch
this is difficult to translate into
point observations but I can imagine
it's it's useful information because we
haven't looked at points we kind of made
observations then there's opportunistic
newly acquired information and you know
they see something say something motto
where does that use new york subway
maybe i don't know maybe here all we
need here is to say look if you're out
there and you see something that you
think is interesting and important to us
just send us a photo just tell us where
you were and send us a geo geo tagged
photo we can see a lots of things from
just a surface photo now we have an idea
already of what's there it's not a
detailed observation but this can help
us a lot there's no protocol the
advantage here is we're not asking you
to fill in any form did you ever get
these things on the web where they say
please take a survey to improve our
website
I just got one from the New York Times
this morning I I subscribe to new york
times I like it and I said okay let me
see and they came up said this will take
10 minutes to complete I said never
forget it I don't want to answer
questions for 10 minutes I mean if
you're just asking me a couple questions
I might do it but in this case there's
no protocol and no complication and
here's an example actually from me which
I did out one day for a bike ride and I
see they done deep ploughing on this
field and you can see these iron huge
iron stone there's iron stone gravels
here and then big big chunks of iron
stone there's a tends to be I there was
one this big what is this this is what
we call bog iron orcs teen in Europe
it's it's a it's a concentration of iron
that's been concentrated by groundwater
and the farmer had decided had this
drainage problem in the field and it
decided to deep rip it for some reason
and brought all these stuff up from
maybe a meter deep and you see all this
stuff you wouldn't normally see and i
went back and look at the soil map and
the two units coming in here this is in
the one to 50,000 soil map but neither
of them say anything about bog iron now
this unit here the the this one of the
stipple does talk about bands of iron of
thin bands of non-continuous iron that
might be precipitating through the
spodek horizon so you'd have a nice very
fine sand spodek arising with little
lines of iron but nothing about this
groundwater iron so this is definitely
wrong I don't know if the original
surveyor didn't dig that deep or what
but you see the soil type is quite a bit
here and so this is something that I
would if they were the mapping project
were active i would say here was my
point here's the photo figure out what's
going on and then they would be
presumably be reinterpreting the
landscape you also see here the dutch
don't think there are any soils in urban
areas so they're way behind other
European colleagues the French and
Germans especially even the US so okay
here's an idea that came from Steve
Carlisle and we worked it out a bit and
the ideas you'd have a map
a project called improve your soil
survey and the idea is you would the
citizens access the online map which you
can always do now anyway I'll show you
that and displaying it on their
smartphone or tablet and then they can
check the soil description that they see
their with what they're seeing on the
ground and they can then report things
that don't seem to match certainly
things on the surface course fragments
or texture things like that you can
easily see and if there's any
discrepancies they could either confirm
or they could send in they say went here
and the idea here is the professional
surveyors in the nrcs in the case of the
US would review this and here's actually
an example from new field this is a
published soil survey map which is
online I I printed it out very nicely
this is all from the our NRCS and I can
print out the map and show it on the on
the the background this is up an Irish
Hill wrote a new field you can also use
I really recommend this location at the
California soil resource lab they've
taken the whole sergo database and
they've made it into something we'll
just show on Google Earth it's super
cool so you can show the soil map on
google earth you can see the perspective
and it's a really nice job and you'll
see they did a good job also in soil
survey so here's this area and if you
click on it you will see it's a Volusia
January silt loam and you will see a
modal profile and if you click on this
you'll get all the all the descriptions
of this but you'll see that this shows
the modal profile going down to almost
two meters and the Volusia but when you
get there some of you may know this spot
this is an at the Natural the Green
Springs natural cemetery up on IRS Hill
Road just before the Arnett for us and
when you get up there you will see that
there's no way the soil is this deep and
it's very consistent in fact if you look
at their website and they asked one of
the FAQ Zyzz can i dig my own grave or
my own relatives grave because that
would be a really nice thing to do I
could you know it's very natural they
say no because after you get to about a
meter you are going to be stuck by this
we need a backhoe because you are not
going to be digging this stuff
down to two meters so they're clear on
that and if you go and look at any of
these graves that are open you see
here's the pile and huge numbers of
rocks have been excavated so clearly the
depth to the bedrock here is much
shallower than mapped and I think the
solution here if you would if this NRCS
would look at this would be to re remap
that I think the whole everything
they're calling the Volusia there is is
pretty is probably not as it's because
it's much as much shallower and there's
another soil series I think when that's
not what is it John it's not it's not
the aren't it's the wetter it's the one
if it's in the iron it sequence but it's
a shallow as aren't it but it's it's the
next wetter one yeah yeah so they could
ya know this would be it's like Arnott
it's like iron it but it's a little bit
it's the wet little bit one range class
sweater but anyway the Lord sound there
would be remapped as iron it and and I
think the reason they did this is when
the in the in the old days when they map
the counties they didn't want to have
too many soil series so if they had only
a small area of one series they
correlated to another so these mappers
may well have known it was shallower
because our net is mapped the iron it
series is mapped a lot in the iron it
forest and in and in in Chemung County
for example but not here because it's
still Tompkins County anyway okay almost
finished here now let's get to the more
difficult part which is the protocol
guided information this is much more
difficult than the opportunistic
observations you have to have a protocol
you have to get the observers you have
to train them and the quality control
though makes this a much more consistent
observation that we you could really use
directly you need a protocol that's
first of all safe that's a very
important thing you can't ask someone to
do something unsafe digging a deep pit
maybe it'll fall in on them or something
like that or they can make pull their
back out digging you know various things
you really have to think about this
we're professionals we're all covered by
well some of us are covered by cornell
health insurance
there's not i still have Dutch okay
anyway but you have all this this is all
very fine but then I guess my question
here when you have this protocol
division you're asking them to to get
training and and to follow a protocol
and really what's the motivation for
them there it's a little bit unclear for
me to see what that would be to be like
being in the volunteer fire department
there's a lot of training involved but
the motivation is clear you're you're
helping your community you're working in
a nice team and so there's a reason you
go through all this training here's what
they did an opal and they have a 16-page
field book just for the earthworm's they
teach the kids how to do this it's very
nice but this is the kind of material
you would need to develop this level of
material if you want to really
consistent they have this they have this
survey step they you have to measure a
20 by 20 meters square centimeter square
you have to do things just right so the
survey is really consistent so that's
why they have high-quality Batum
physical samples could be submitted for
analysis but I'm a little reluctant
about that because all of these issues
here finding a representative site
preparing the site you know the surface
soil sampling it putting the bag all
that I just find is probably maybe a bit
difficult the last thing I think is the
precision agriculture and this is
something that I thought about I don't
know if this is really citizen science
as such because the farmer the farmer is
a citizen of course but I think the
problem here is there's a lot I mean a
lot has been done on this but I think
most of this data ends up being
proprietary that farmers do not want to
release this there might be a way to say
we will use your data to help us improve
our map but we won't show your data
directly and there might be a ways to do
that but again this would take some time
to convince people okay so these are my
conclusions we think that we could
increase our spatio-temporal density
somehow with this so less glamorous but
there is a community of people us we
hope like it and maybe we were improved
you know we're very attracted now our
environmental
is major more and more people are
interested environment than agriculture
it's just good and maybe our numbers are
increasing so then the last thing is
that the citizen scientist is me and one
of my co-authors this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu